beton und stahl überall werden sie
gebraucht beim bauen von straßen und
brücken wohnungen und fabriken doch
gleichzeitig sind sie die größten
klimakiller der deutschen industrie
allein bei der herstellung entstehen
jedes jahr mehr als 50 millionen tonnen
co2
diese co2 emissionen müssen schnell
sinken nur dann kann deutschland seine
klimaschutzziele erreichen
verabredung mit dem energieexperten
frank-peter er ist überzeugt bisher habe
die deutsche stahl und beton industrie
viel zu wenig für mehr klimaschutz getan
die emission in london bei der industrie
haben eigentlich über die letzten zehn
jahren nur stagniert und es wird dadurch
klar dass wir auf diesem pfad nicht
weitermachen können dabei hätten die
co2-emissionen der industrie schon
längst sinken sollen dank des so
genannten emissionshandels der eu der
gilt seit 2005 und funktioniert so ein
unternehmen muss für jede ausgestoßene
tonne co2 zertifikate von der eu kaufen
das kostet geld um geld zu sparen wird
aus unternehmen die emissionen
reduzieren soweit die theorie
in der praxis aber hat die eu die
allermeisten co2 zertifikate verschenkt
der emissionshandel hat definitiv in der
vergangenheit nicht gut funktioniert wir
haben zu viele emissionen zertifikate im
system ausgegeben das hat im prinzip
dazu geführt dass es dass wir viel zu
viele zertifikate haben dass die preise
keine lenkungswirkung haben und das
entsprechend auch kein druck
hinsichtlich zu ihm hin zur
emissionsreduktion für die industrie
gegeben wurde statt druck für mehr
klimaschutz erhält die industrie viele
wertvolle gratis zertifikate
amsterdam
der daten journalist look sängers von
der holländischen wochenzeitung die
grüne amsterdamer hat sich das genauer
angesehen und die offiziellen daten der
eu kommission ausgewertet
wir haben uns auf die 100 größten klima
verschmutzer konzentriert und untersucht
welche unternehmen mehr gratis
zertifikate bekommen haben als sie
eigentlich für ihre co2 emissionen
brauchen die koffer vor der aktuelle
mission
das erstaunliche ergebnis von luke
sängers berechnung 40 unternehmen
erhielten mehr zertifikate geschenkt als
sie benötigten rund 820 millionen zu
viel beim heutigen co2 preis entspricht
das einem gewinn von rund 41 milliarden
euro
von diesen 100 unternehmen haben etwa 40
am handelssystem verdient an einem
system das eingerichtet wurde um die
verursacher für ihre verschmutzung
zahlen zu lassen doch im gegenteil sie
ziehen gewinne daraus
einer der größten gewinner des systems
ist heidelberg cement der konzern bekam
seit 2008 gut 45 millionen zertifikate
mehr als er brauchte beim heutigen co2
preis ein geschenk aus brüssel im wert
von mehr als zwei milliarden euro
was sagt heidelberg cement dazu auf
nachfrage erklärt der konzern
schriftlich zitat
aus wettbewerblichen gründen äußern wir
uns nicht zu unseren handelsaktivitäten
fest steht die co2 emissionen der
deutschen zementindustrie sind seit
einführung des emissionshandels
2005 bis heute nicht gesunken 2020 lagen
sie bei 20,1 millionen tonnen
genauso viel wie vor 16 jahren
dabei ist die technik für mehr
klimaschutz links dar
das zeigt die holländische baustofffirma
new horizon sie setzt auf beton
recycling vom abriss eines bauwerks über
das zerkleinern zerlegen reinigen bis
hin zum so genannten smart liebe ritter
die recycling maschine trend alten beton
in seiner hauptbestandteile sand kies
und zement reste damit wird dann neuer
beton hergestellt mit deutlich weniger
emissionen
commission world von allen co2
emissionen weltweit stammen allein neun
prozent aus der traditionellen
produktion von beton
wenn wir also mit unserem beton mehr als
60 prozent einsparen dann haben wir für
die umwelt einen großen schritt getan er
war mental
beton mit 60 prozent weniger co2 doch
die firma hat es schwer im wettbewerb
trotz emissionshandel der konkurrent
heidelbergcement etwa könnte seinen
klimaschädlichen beton deutlich
günstiger anbieten erklärt das
unternehmen
ich finde das unfair denn wer ordentlich
co2 emittiert wird dafür sogar noch
belohnt
und es wird noch verrückter viele
unternehmen stellen die geschenkten
zertifikate ihren kunden in rechnung
indem sie die preise erhöhen das haben
wissenschaftler aus den niederlanden
konkret für einzelne unternehmen
berechnet
bei heidelberg cement kommen sie auf
einen profit von zusätzlich 285
millionen euro
heidelberg cement erklärt auf nachfrage
dieser gewinnen sei rein theoretischer
natur zitat aus
wettbewerbsrechtlichen gründen können
wir uns zu einer etwaigen weitergabe von
co2 kosten an kunden nicht im detail
äußern
die ökonomien carolin schmid wundert es
nicht dass unternehmen ihren kunden
gratis zertifikate in rechnung stellen
also auf der einen seite kann man sagt
ja schön dreist auf der anderen seite
betriebswirtschaftlich rational für ein
unternehmen wenn ich höhere preise
erlösen kann dann mache ich das so
funktionieren märkte und so profitiert
vom emissionshandel die industrie weil
die eu die co2 zertifikate nicht etwa
verkauft sondern einfach verschenkt und
die industrie stellt ihren kunden diese
zertifikate obendrein in rechnung obwohl
sie selbst nichts dafür bezahlt hat ein
wahnsinns geschäft für die deutsche
industrie extra gewinne von rund zehn
milliarden euro so die berechnungen der
niederländischen wissenschaftler
wie konnte es dazu kommen
rückblick für die gratis zertifikate hat
die industrie in der vergangenheit immer
wieder gekämpft bei jeder reform des
emissionshandels gegen den arbeiter der
konzerne auf die straße ohne gratis
zertifikate seien hunderttausende
arbeitsplätze in gefahr so die drohung
die industrie ist in europa gut
aufgestellt was ihre eigenen interessen
angeht es gibt sehr sehr viele kontakte
die entsprechend auch dann genutzt
werden besonders gut aufgestellt ist die
stahlindustrie mit ihrem lobbyverband
wir treffen dessen geschäftsführer
martin teuringer der wand einmal mehr
vor abwanderung der betriebe die gratis
zertifikate seien weiterhin
unverzichtbar
jede tonne co2 die aus deutschland und
europa in den rest der welt gelegt wird
also abwandert verlieren wir hier rund
5000 arbeitsplätze ohne dass wir irgend
einem positiven klimaschutzeffekt
erzielen diese gratis zur teilung wie
lange glauben sie dass sie brauchen für
den übergang und aus unserer sicht mit
dieser übergang mindestens in die 2030er
wenn nicht sogar in die 2000 40er jahre
dauern
die forderungen der industrie fanden
noch immer gehör bei der bundesregierung
auch heute noch nachfrage beim
verantwortlichen staatssekretär im
bundesumweltministerium
aufgabe politik ist das
ungerechtfertigte gejammer von dem zu
trennen was tatsächlich ein problem
besteht und da dann auch zu helfen ist
das gelungen nein das ist nicht immer
gelungen wir haben in der tat da das
will ich gar nicht bestreiten
auch im emissionshandelssystem fehler
gehabt die sind beglichen worden das
hätte man auch ein stück früher machen
können gar keine frage aber ich glaube
das system ist jetzt robust aufgestellt
und wird seinen dienst zu tun
erstaunlich denn die bundesregierung
will der industrie weiter co2
zertifikate schenken genauso wie die
deutsche eu kommissionspräsident in von
der leyen vor wenigen wochen schlug sie
vor die industrie soll auch weiterhin
co2 zertifikate gratis erhalten erst
einmal bis 2025
es bleibt also vorerst alles beim alten
wettbewerbsnachteile für unternehmen mit
klimafreundlichen lösungen und extra
profite für klimasünder